so you won't tie my toothpicks are there
raisins in this yeah okay so here we are
my best friend Adam is challenging me to
make this jiggly cheesecake today that
has been popularized in Japan here's the
jiggles they start with lining the pan
with raisins and there's the Cheesecake
and then there's like a very smooth
rounded top which then I'm gonna brand
because that's what they do in Japan so
I'm gonna brand this cheesecake as my
own today so the first thing you need to
do is I need to line my baking pan
that's how we're gonna pop it right out
this is a tricky part I need one hundred
and thirty milliliters of milk
i can'twe milk right really oh no it's
too much
like gross this is on medium heat 200
grams of butter with the same amount of
cream cheese cumshaw milk until it's all
kind of like melted down into this nice
creamy mixture so while that's happening
I'm gonna crack some eggs these are
gonna mix drizzle this into the egg
yolks I'm gonna put flour and cornstarch
into my cream cheese and egg yolks
mixture I am ready to whisk my egg
whites but I will have to gradually add
sugar so I'm gonna add some cream of
tartar in tartar tartar is it like
tartar sauce it's not the same anyways
I'm putting some cream of tartar and I
don't know how much of this to use cream
of tartar it can help make stiffer peaks
that's pretty stiff to me now I have to
slowly fold in the egg whites big ol
bowl they just like it a big school and
it pours in pretty well also I got to
put raisins on the bottom here we go I
feel kind of okay about this but this
goes in here putting this in the oven
I'm gonna pour the water into the water
bath I think it's gonna be heavy
and breathe in it I think we did it I
think we did it
you do tonight oh my god a [ __ ] it's
tall the ground huh
[Music]
oh it cuts nice
[Music]
Ross Adam compare this
[Music]
Oh
[Music]